okay so welcome to this a CT math
spur-of-the-moment review session I'm
going to be going through some typical a
CT math problems that you're going to
want to know for the a CT and I also
want to encourage students that if you
want additional help and you like my
teaching style and you've been watching
my videos to check out my huge a CT math
review video course I've got a link in
the description below so you can check
that out if you're interested in
learning more about the typical concepts
and problems that you're going to be
seeing on the a CT so let's jump into it
I've got four questions that are typical
problems that you're going to want to
know how to you know how to solve so see
if you can solve these and we'll see if
there's time for a question and answer
at the end of this little four question
a little review that I've got here so
see if we can jump into this let's look
at example number one tell me how you
would go ahead and solve this so it says
if a to be the ratio a to be is four to
three and the ratio of C to B is eight
to 27 what is the ratio of A to C so
what do you think how would you solve
that problem go ahead and put your ideas
in the chat and we'll go ahead and solve
it here in just a minute but basically
you know when you write a ratio you know
you can use this colon you can use the
word to you can write it as a fraction
but you know ratio you're just comparing
two quantities so what do you think how
would you how would you solve that
particular problem so I've got four
questions that we're going to go through
so stay tuned these are typical problems
they're not super challenging they're
kind of you know middle-of-the-road but
definitely things that you want to know
for the practice test so let's see I
guess I'll jump into this one and see if
see if I'm on the right track here so
we've got a 2 B right they tell us
that's equal to 4 2 3 right and they
tell us that C to be a high Aryan Sharma
welcome and the ratio of C to B is 8 to
27 but what do you think the ratio of B
to C would be B to C well that's going
to be 20
seven to eight alright twenty seven to
eight but what we really want is the
ratio of A to C over here so what we're
going to do is we're going to take a to
be okay and then what we're going to do
is we're going to multiply that by the
ratio of B to C and notice how the B's
cancel so now we've got a ratio a to C
and that's what we're looking for so all
we have to do is take 4/3 times twenty
seven eighths oh that's on trending
sorry I'm not responding it's been a
while since I've done a live stream so
I'm just trying to see if I can work
through this problem but yeah I'll
respond to all your comments in the chat
and in just a second so it's been a
while since I've been live here but I
wanted to kind of help out some students
and you know just kind of get you guys
started with some of these a CT math
problems so here you go we've got 4/3
times 27 over 8 and notice you can
reduce three goes in here once 3 goes in
here 9 times 4 and 8 you can both reduce
so if you multiply across here you can
see we're going to get a ratio of 9 over
2 so did I do that right okay so you see
how that works so basically what you're
doing is you're multiplying the two
ratios they put a little bit of a twist
on the problem here see a 2 B and then C
2 B so what we had to do is we had to
take the reciprocal of C 2 B so that we
can get these B's to cancel out on the
diagonal so that's the typical problem
that you'll see on that AC T sometimes
just understanding knowing knowing how
to work with ratios and multiplying the
ratios together sorry with me so far is
that making sense so welcome to everyone
that's come out so why are you taking
the AC T on the 14th is everyone jumping
in on that next AC tir'd July 14th
okay Eric problems Bradley says that
you're you guess I can't hear okay yeah
so this is coming up in just a little
bit here that's on training says no
problem
okay great okay well let's take a look
at the next problem see if you guys can
do this problem okay number two it says
given that C is equal to three x squared
times y over Z cubed what happens to C
if X is doubled and Z is multiplied by
one half so what do you think what would
happen here so it says given this
equation what happens to C the C value
right here if X is doubled and Z is
multiplied by one half so I'll just give
you a second to see if you cannot solve
this problem this is typical you know a
typical type of problem that they have
am a CT so what do you how would you do
that one well you know this is a tough
one you know because sometimes students
they see all these variables that get a
little bit confused so what I would do
on a problem like this is I would take
our values so we're doubling act so that
means that X is going to be now 2x and
we're squaring it okay and then for Z
you can see that we're multiplying Z by
one half but that quantity were cubing
so if we just keep going here notice how
this is like two squared so that means
that this is now the numerator is four
times larger I carry with me so far but
here we have one half times Z but we're
cubing that so that means this is really
going to be like one eighth of its
previous value but what happens when we
divide by a fraction
well you multiply by the reciprocal so
this is really going to be like 4 over 1
times 8 over 1 which is equal to 32 so
it means that C is actually going to be
32 times larger so with me so far on
that so this is a typical problem on
there it might not be the same equation
but it's understanding you know how to
make these substitutions you know a lot
of times students will just think oh
well you know it's it's doubled ok so
it's going to be doubled you know but
you
to take into account that you know that
it's actually the quantity squared okay
so let's go to a number three now so see
if you can do Psalm number three so
let's see number three e alright so take
a look at this one see if you can solve
this it says which region or regions
show the solution set of y is greater
than or equal to one-half X plus four or
y is less than or equal to negative two
x plus six so what do you think if you
had to guess on this one do you think
its region a B C or D and notice it can
be region or regions right so it could
be plural here it could be more than one
so if you had to figure this out what do
you think I'll give you a minute to to
think about this so so yeah so welcome
to the live stream if you're just
joining me here I just thought I'd just
jump on here I've been busy with a lot
of different projects here lately
and I haven't had time to really jump on
here on the live stream so I just wanted
to kind of connect with the some of the
viewers and just kind of try to see if I
can help you out with some typical AC T
math problems so if you can solve these
you know you're out you're well on your
way to definitely scoring higher on the
test so let me see if I can jump in here
so it's C okay let's see rate region
blend one says it's region B what do you
think is he or she correct what do you
think is it region B well okay you see
this line right here okay and see how it
says y is greater than or equal to
one-half X plus 4 so that's this line
right here greater than we're shading
above okay see when the y is by itself
like this that's controlling the
vertical direction Y is greater than
we're shade above that line right so if
I was to shade that it would be like
right here okay but this line y is less
than or equal to negative 2x plus 6
that's this line okay less than when the
Y's by itself less it means you're
shading below why controls the vertical
directions so we're actually shading on
this side right okay but now here's the
here's where our rate and land basically
made a little bit of a mistake what is
good a good effort though you see this
word of or what
what does war mean in math okay there's
a word or and there's the word an so do
you know the difference between Oren and
well in math or actually means Union so
when you just see the word or you're
thinking the union of the two sets so
Union means like you're combining them
together so that means it's actually
going to be region a region B as well as
region C so it's actually a B C's okay
now if it said and and in math means
intersection it means the overlap of the
two sets okay welcome Erin to the live
stream here so if it was and then the
overlapping region would be B so that's
what we're used to doing in our math
classes but on the AC T they oftentimes
test us on what's the difference between
and and or this was or or means Union it
means both okay Maddie welcome to the
live stream we're just going through
some typical AC t-- math questions here
to help you boost your score and I don't
know if I mentioned this at the
beginning of the live stream but if
you're interested in my huge AC t-- math
review video course I go through 65
concepts as well as a number of example
problems covering those different
concepts that are often covered on the
AC t-- math section so check that out
I've got three free previews over there
there's a link in the description below
if you want to check that out to get
some additional help but let's go to the
number for example number four here
typical AC t-- math problems is what
we're working on here today and it says
how many real solutions are there to the
equation 3x squared minus 2x plus 1
equals zero so what do you think how
many real solutions are there to this
equation hmm what do you think any ideas
any what would you do if you had a
problem like this how would you find out
how many real solutions there are that's
the key key phrase well let's see I mean
you could graph it right that's one
possibility so when you graph a
quadratic like this you know wherever it
crosses the x-axis all right those would
be your solutions like right there okay
that's where it's equal to zero
so that's one way to do it so you could
graph it what's an
their way well you can see it's a
quadratic we could do the quadratic
formula right remember your quadratic
formula this is an important one for the
AC t negative B plus or minus the square
root of b squared minus 4ac all divided
by 2a and there's a third way and you
want to know what that third way is okay
so just a second error and after this
one we can address your question there's
a third way and that's using the
discriminant so what's the discriminant
that's the b squared minus 4ac right so
if the b squared minus 4ac if it's
greater than zero we have two real
solutions and it's equal to zero we have
one real solution if it's less than zero
we have no real solutions right so in
this case we just have to look at our a
value our B value and our C value right
substitute them into the discriminant
and see if it's positive zero or
negative right so let's go ahead and do
that so B squared is going to give us 4
minus 4 times a times C so you can see
that's coming out to 4 minus 12 which is
negative 8 okay wait so it's negative so
what does that tell us it tells us that
it's actually this case right here it's
less than 0 it's negative that means
there's no real solutions which means if
we were to graph this quadratic it's
actually you know could look something
like this or it could look like this but
it's not going to cross that x-axis it's
never going to equal 0 so the answer to
this question would be there's no real
solutions ok so we just have a few
minutes I just had a just had a few
moments to kind of jump here in here on
this live stream to show you some of
these typical questions again if you
want to learn more about typical
questions that are covered on the acct
math section go to the description and
for this video and I've got a link to my
video course on the huge AC t-- math 65
concepts covered and there's three free
previews over there so you can check out
the previews to see what the course is
like you can learn something from that
and then if you want to get the course
you can go ahead and do that but right
now we're just kind of going through
some basic problems but let's let me go
back into the chat
and kind of Stephen questions but I
didn't I didn't catch him so they go
back into the livestream here and see
okay Aaron was asking the equation 24x
squared post 25 X minus 47 let's see
what else
minus 2 equals negative 8x minus 3 minus
53 it's true for all values of X not
equal to 2 a where a is a constant what
is the value of a hmm let's see this
it's a good question so that's a great
question
a Sherman on that you know on here I'm
not really sure I'll try to write it
down for it for everyone in case you
want to see if you can solve it so
Aaron's basically asking if you have 24
x squared
c plus 25 at 47 now what what's this
other part it said a X minus 2 what's
this a X minus 2 let's here I'll just
kind of write it like he wrote it a X
minus 2 equals negative 8x minus 3 minus
53 a X minus 2 is true for all values
where X does not equal to a and a is a
constant what's the value of 16 negative
3 3 or 16 okay so I don't know I'm
having a little bit trouble
understanding exactly what that question
is there and so I apologize about that
ok other questions other other things
that maybe students have questions about
regarding the acct math coming up here
July 14th
anything else maybe I can answer so we
just have a couple a few more minutes
here just to kind of talk about a CT
math but go back if you're just joining
the livestreams check out the 4 problems
we just solve those are typical problems
but if you have other questions go ahead
and ask them right now in the chat I'll
see if I can address them so all hmm so
what do you think gave me any questions
what do you think
well if you head over onto my Mario's
math tutoring YouTube channel if you go
to the just to that first page there
I've got like some playlists on
different problems that are on the a CT
math section so you can look at that if
you're looking for additional help
let's see Aaron's got another question
so it says if X is the average okay of M
and Y and Y is the average of two M + 15
+ Z is the average of 3 M + 18 what is
the average of XY and Z in terms of M
okay Errin so you're asking some good
questions okay so I can see your you're
really thinking about these concepts so
let me see if I can write this down so
basically what Aaron's saying oh you
know this live the live chat it kind of
disappears quickly on my screen so let
me see if I can hold this here so it
says X is the average of M and Y so that
means it's m m+ y / - right and Y is the
average of 2 M + 15 so 2m + 15 okay so
average means you're adding a look at
dividing by how many there are and then
Z is the average of 3 M + 18 all right
so 3 M + 18 divided by 2 what is the
average of XY and Z in terms of M okay
so here's the thing here and so if
you're doing the average of XY and Z
that means it's going to be x + y + Z
divided by 3 right so all we have to do
is add all these together now so you can
see it's going to be let's see M plus y
over 2 + 2 M plus 1500 did I say M + y
oh this is M and nine right MN 9 okay so
that's M plus 9 divided by 2 + 2 M plus
15 over 2 plus 3 M plus I'm running out
of room 18
/ - okay if you add all those up and get
divided by 3 that's going to be your
average
right so so all we have to do now is
just combine these together so we've got
n plus 2 n plus 3 on that 6 15 plus 9 is
plus 18 is haha how much is that 42 and
that's all divided by 2 and then that's
all divided by 3 but when you divide by
3 that's like multiplying by 1/3 right
1/3 so this really comes out to 6 M plus
42 all divided by 6 which is M plus 7
which which option was that that was
letter B okay so did you understand how
we did that problem so that's a really
good question Erin you know it they're
oftentimes asked average questions on
the ACG math section so really knowing
the average formula you know you add up
and divide by how many you have that's
the average that's really important so
excellent question
let's see mahdi is asking a question
let's see the quadratic equation for the
cost in dollars are producing the
automobile tires is good where X is the
number of tires a company produces find
the number of tires that will minimize
the cost okay so let's see Maddie let me
grab another sheet of paper here let's
look at your question
everyone if you can solve Maddie's
question see if you can do this so it's
point zero zero boy you got some really
tough numbers here point zero zero zero
zero two x squared minus point zero four
X plus 38 okay now you want to minimize
the cost so here's the thing let me see
if I can just tell you how to do the
prom see if you're trying to minimize
the cost notice how this is a parabola
right so if it's a parabola that means
that the a value tells us whether it's
opening up or down so since a is
positive that means it's going to be
opening up right which is going to be
giving us a minimum where does that
minimum occur it occurs where the vertex
is right so what you would do is you
would find the vertex and now that x
coordinate of the vertex would be the
number of tires is going to you know
minimize the cost well how do you find
the vertex well you need to know this
formula right it's the negative B over
2a
this is our a this is our B and this is
our C so that's how you would do it
Madhi so if you can figure out negative
B over 2a is that's the number of two
fires this is that help so if if you
haven't subscribed to the channel yet
and you like my you like my teaching
style go ahead and subscribe to the
channel and if you like this video and
you look these livestream so be sure to
give me a thumbs up let me know that
tell you you enjoy the assault I'll do
more of them in the future and let's see
if there's any other last questions I
just had a just a few moments here to
kind of jump on here so let me just see
if there's any other questions I can
answer but I appreciate everyone for
being here and like I said if you're
interested in learning more about you
know kind of some typical questions that
are covered on the AC t-- math section
go into the description of this video
check out the huge AC t-- math review
video course that I put together
covering 65 concepts and I show you like
the concepts and typical problems that
you know or use those concepts so
definitely check that out I also have a
link for that on my about page on my
youtube channel also check out the
playlists over there on my Morrow's math
tutor youtube channel covering a CT math
SAT math as well as well as videos for
your math course so let's just see if
there's any last question I think Erin
had another question let me see here and
it says for a polynomial P of X the
value of P of 3 is negative 2 okay so
let's let's write this down here and so
P of 3 is equal to negative 2 which do
the following must be true X ok it says
8 X minus 5 is a factor of the
polynomial B X minus 2 is a factor of
the polynomial C X plus 2 is a factor of
the polynomial or D the remainder when P
of X is a divided by X minus 3 is
negative 2
Erin it's going to be d and the reason
it's D is is why well see with letter A
see how it's the next minus 5 is a
factor well the only way okay so let me
see if I can explain this to everyone
listening here's the idea if they say
that 5 is a zero okay that means when
you put 5 into your polynomial zeros
what comes out then you can say that X
- five is a factor so do you want to
understand this question for that a CT
and an SAT so the five is a 0 but X - 5
is a factor a factor means that this
binomial here is going to divide in
evenly okay into the polynomial without
any remainder so that's why if you look
at here let's see in the chat says X - 5
is a factor
no because 5 is not not equal to 0 and x
- 2 is not a factor because 2 is not
equal to 0 and x + 2 is not a factor
because negative 2 is not equal to 0 so
it has to be letter D that when you're
divided by X - 3 that the the remainder
is negative 2 so that's you can do it by
process of elimination that's one way to
look at that problem ok so I think
that's it going to be about it I just
want to thank you know everyone for
showing up Matty Aaron see who else was
in here today just raid ragin lead one
Aryan shun trending this here boss I was
here
Bradley yes I want to thank everyone for
showing up again check out that a huge a
CT math review video course for more
help I look forward to seeing you guys
and my channel and to helping you in the
future so I'll toast for uh thanks again
for being